البطاله او التسريح بالجمله شبح اخر يصيب
هذه المره العاملين في كبرى شركات
التكنولوجيا لمع نجمهم في العصر الرقمي
لكنهم باتو يمرون بمنعطف كبير وسريع
عنوانه الركود الاقتصادي مع ارتفاع
التكاليف وضع في سوق الاعلانات
ليس ذلك فحسب بل ان العاملين في هذا
المجال يواجهون واقعا جديدا تحول فيه
التوظيف في الساحه الرقميه الى حرب مواهب
وفق معن ولد صحيفه
الامريكيه التي اكدت ان العمل في هذا
العالم الافتراضي مر بفتره حرجه
واستشهدت الصحيفه بما جرى خلال الفتره
الماضيه فلم تكن وحدها منصه تويتر احدثت
عاصفه بتسريح نصف موظفيها لان مجموعه ميته
الملكه للفيسبوك وانستجرام استغنت لاول
مره في تاريخها عن احد 10,000 خلال اسبوع
ويضاف اليهما عملاق محرك البحث جوجل الذي
اغلقه هو الاخر مجال توظيف
وبحسب الصحيفه فان الموظفين العاملين في
هذا القطاع التكنولوجي يعتدوا على مناصب
برواسب كبيره وحزن اسهم
لكنهم امام هذا الوضع باتو يواجهون
البطاله لاول مره في حياتهم المهنيه الى
جانب تقلص صافي ثرواتهم معا انخفاض قيم
التداول بعد ما شهد هذا القطاع حقبه تطور
ادهشت العالم باسره لعقد من الزمن اذا
اكدت البيانات ان التوظيف في هذا المجال
ارتفع بنسبه 28% في 2022 مقارنه بالعام
السابق لكن موجات التسريح دفعت البعض الى
العمل لساعات طوال خوفا من فقدان عملهم او
سهوله استبدالهم فمن الصوت التوظيف تضج
بالطلبات لا سيما في الشركات الناشئه التي
تستقطب بعض المواهب من الشركات الكبرى
لكنها مع ذلك لن تكون كافيه لاستيعاب جميع
الخسائر اسراء الصغير العربيه